دبي عجيب و50 موعد برامج في قناه العربيه
عقيد مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
دائما كل فيلم وثائقي يبدا همم فكره وبعد
ذلك الفكره تتحول الى الرؤيا الرؤيه ايضا
تنفذ اريد السؤال هنا عن الفكره كيف بدات
وكم استغرق العمل ايضا على هذا الفيلم
اهلا وسهلا بك بك نايف همم اتفق معك في
الفكره اللي اللي طرحتها تعرف نايف ان
الحديث حول همم
التغير المناخ همم
ومشاريع الطاقه المتجدده عالميا اصبح واحد
من المواضيع الحيويه اللي تضل تسمع عنها
كل يوم على المستوى المحلي او على المستوى
العالمي همم مشاريع الطاقه المتجدده او
محور الطاقه المتجدده استحود على جزء من
همم رؤيه 2030 في السعوديه همم كان في
التزامات السعوديه تجاه هذا هذا المحور
همم السنه الماضيه نايف كان في همم حديث
لوزير الطاقه السعودي الامير عبد العزيز
بن سلمان في واحد من اجتماعات اوبك همم
حديث وزير الطاقه السعودي في هذا الاجتماع
كان هو همم شراره الفكره بالنسبه لي انا
كمعد همم برامج للعمل او للبحث همم في عمل
همم وثائقي بخصوص هذا الموضوع
الساده الماضيه همم وزير الطاقه السعودي
قال انه على العالم ان ينظر لنا بطريقه
مختلفه من السعوديه لم تعد فقط بلد همم
يصدر الطاقه البتروليه او الوقود الاحفوري
فقط الى الى العالم السعوديه سوف تكون في
مقدمه الدول اللي تصدر الطاقه بجميع
اشكالها وجميع انواعها ممتاز المستقبل
القريب وان على العالم القبول بهذه
الحقيقه
التصريح هذا طرح في بالي تساؤلات لانه
بالضبط شو هي المشاريع اللي قاعد يصير على
الارض همم كيف وكيف يمشي العمل عليها في
السعوديه حاليا طيب يعني او حالي بمرحله
انتقاليه حقيقيه تعيش السعوديه
من المواقع المهمه في هذه المشاريع ربما
المشاريع الموجوده من قبل المشاريع الطاقه
المتجدده ومشاريع الجديده مناطق ربما لم
يصل اليها صحفيين حتى الان ما الذي لفت
انتباهك وتعتقد بانه همم شيء لم يسبق لاحد
ان يطلع عليه او حتى ان يكتب عنا او ان
ينقل ايضا حتى للمشاهدين
قال يعني في الحقيقه لما كنت انزل على
الارض لاماكن المشاريع كان في بالي ثلاثه
او اربع محاور كنت همم ابحث همم على اجوبه
همم بخصوصها همم الفكره الاولى الصناعه
الجديده اللي راح توصل للمنطقه همم هذه
كيف راح يستقبلها اهل همم المنطقه همم من
راح يشغل هذه المشاريع من راح يمدها
بالخدمات همم المسانده ويعمل على تطويرها
مع الوقت همم كل منطقه كنا نوصل لها نايف
كنت لاحظ ان اهل المنطقه نفسهم او ابناء
المنطقه هم الذين يقومون بتشغيل همم هذه
المشاريع وادارتها وكثيره
الى عدنان
صحيح صحيح يعني
في في سكاكا مثلا مشروع الطاقه الشمسيه
كامل الفريق اللي يشغل محطه الطاقه
الشمسيه ويديرها هو فريق سعودي من اهل
الجوف قامت الشركه المطوره للمشروع هذا
بتدريبهم للعمل في هذا في هذا المشروع نفس
الشيء بالنسبه لمحطه تحليه المياه في
في رابغ في عندك عاملين العامل الاول
نوعيه التعليم اللي حصل عليها ابناء
المناطق السعوديه سواء داخل السعوديه او
خارجها اهلتهم ان هم ممكن انه همم
يستقبلوها مثل هذه المشاريع ويشغلونها على
وجه السرعه بكفاءه همم عاليه النقطه
الثانيه في هذه المشاريع نايف لانه هذه
المشاريع تضمن همم التنميه التي تمتد لكل
المناطق السعوديه وما تنحصر في مناطق همم
معينه همم همم الفكره الثالثه اللي كلفتت
انتباهي نايف انه المشاريع اللي تم همم
انشاءها وتشغيلها حاليا هي قصص همم نجاح
حققت ارقام همم
جيده جدا
وتنبا بمستقبل افضل لبقيه المشاريع
القادمه من خلال السنوات همم الجايه يعني
في مجال تحليه المياه السعوديه تدريجيا
تنتقل من محطات التحليه همم التقليديه الى
محطات همم التحليه بالتناضح العكسي همم
خلال السنه الماضيه همم هذه المحطات فقط
من همم اطلاق الكربون بحوالي 28 مليون طن
من الكربون في الهواء هذه همم
حتى 20 و30 انا انا اشكرك جزيل همم شكرا
ادعوا طبعا كل همم نشاه الرابعه ان يتابع
هذا الفيلم الوعد الاخضر هو موجود على
حساب قناه العربيه في يوتيوب شكرا جزيلا
همم لك من دبي على الجيب و 50 برامج في
قناه العربيه